apenas quedan cuatro días para el
segundo aniversario de la explosión del
puerto de beirut la mayor tragedia que
ha vivido el líbano en los últimos años
donde murieron más de 210 personas y
ahora el silo del puerto de beirut
exactamente la parte norte como pueden
ver detrás de mí ha empezado a colapsar
después de unas semanas que ha sufrido
fuertes incendios que no han sido
controlados debido a las altas
temperaturas de la fermentación del
trigo desde hace unas semanas ya se
advertía que podría colapsar el silo y
las autoridades habían mandado una
circular a las familias que viven en el
centro de beirut para que tome medidas
como es llevar mascarilla cuando salgan
a la calle y tener las puertas y
ventanas cerradas la demolición del
puerto de beirut ya estaba en el
parlamento desde hace unos meses donde
se apoyó un proyecto de ley pero se
encontró con el rechazo de las familias
de las víctimas de la explosión del
puerto que quieren una investigación
donde el silo podía ser una de las
pruebas más importantes hay varios
proyectos en estos momentos rondando de
parte de gran bretaña de alemania o de
eeuu para hacer un nuevo siglo algo que
realmente necesita el líbano porque este
es y lo era el más importante y como por
culpa de la crisis económica y la crisis
global del trigo este país necesita más
que muchos otros poder tener una
importación de trigo